Let's go next to our caller from the two one
zero area code color from two one zero.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
[inaudible]
uh, name's Tony.
I'm calling from San Antonio, Texas, as you
can probably tell from the accent.
[inaudible]
all right.
Tony, what's on your mind today?
I have a quick question.
Yeah, I had a quick question.
First of all, just need to see if you saw
recently on the news that um, a bunch of Republicans
just storms the congressional hearing.
No, I didn't see that.
Okay.
So there's a large group of Republicans that
just owned the congressional hearing where
the Pentagon representative is being questioned.
Um, I had a quick question that kind of revolves
around that and it's as this, uh, goes forward
with the impeachment hearings and as we learn
more and more about, um, issues that come
with this president, this very turmoil base
president, where do you see this evolving,
I guess is the best way.
It is.
How violent.
Uh, is this going to end up?
And what do you think the overall reaction
is going to be from the government moving
forward?
The reaction to what I, I just, I'm not sure
Tony, I'm understanding your question.
[inaudible]
so the, the reaction of a, sorry, I may have
worded that as I'm seeing it, there's a lot
more Republicans that are saying they're talking
about a civil war and all that.
Uh, and I'm sure it's all just bark, no bite.
But it seeming more and more like it's, it's
becoming, uh, more and less aggressive.
Like they are pushing more aggressively when
it comes to investigations.
So I am kind of wondering what your take on
it is, how far you think it's going to go
and what the overall outcome.
So I think that basically this is just a building
of tension.
You have forces investigating the president
for good reason and then you have mostly Republicans
opposing it publicly, even though there are
people like Anthony Scaramucci who say that
privately, there is actually a lot of disdain
for Donald Trump among the Republican party.
So I think that the tension will build and
Republicans will publicly push back against
the investigations as much as they can and
then it'll either get pushed over one way
or the other way.
It will either become what some something
like what Anthony Scaramucci says, which is
Republicans will eventually have no choice
but to just sort of give up and say, you know
what?
Yeah, Trump's got to go.
Uh, this has to end at some point.
Or you will see that it looks that as though
Donald Trump is going to be able to escape
this unscathed, at least to the extent of
removal, we'll see what the result of the
November, 2020 election are.
And the Republicans who stayed with Trump
will sort of appear to be victorious and,
and at least claim to be on the right side,
but it could go either way.
It's really going to depend on public opinion
in the end.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the biggest question I had there.
I just wanted to, as far as living here and
I'm originally from a different Southern state,
but I grew up, uh, as a farmer's kid and tend
to getting concerned as far as it goes.
I don't know why someone, anybody in the South
wants to support a silver spoon fed and kinda
rich guy, but you know, whatever.
Um, I'm kinda concerned about my family and
their thoughts and their process and I want
to make sure, especially with the rumors of
liberal hunting parties, which is ridiculous,
um, that what people's overall aspect of the
outcome is.
I would like it not to evolve into something,
I guess a violent, I guess that's the best
way to put it in the overall tendency of it.
Absolutely.
That's my view as well.
I am against the violence.
Uh, Tony, I appreciate the call from San Antonio.
I've got to move on.
I hope to hear from you again.